every day we get updated figures of the
number of covered 19 cases here in the
UK and the number of deaths they have
just come in that speak to skies Inzamam
Russia in our newsroom is around one of
the figures today so this is the latest
from the Department of Health as they
put out their update usually around this
time every day they say that as of 9
a.m. on the 29th of March a total of a
hundred and twenty seven thousand seven
hundred and thirty seven have been
tested of that a hundred and eight
thousand two hundred and fifteen have
come back negative 19 thousand five
hundred and twenty-two have come back
positive and as a 5:00 p.m. on the 28th
of March yesterday of those hospitalized
in the UK 1228 have sadly died so up
from yesterday's notification from the
Department of Health it is increased by
two hundred and nine deaths now my
calculations suggest us around a twenty
percent increase which is down from the
previous day we saw around a 34 percent
increase in the previous day this is a
20 percent increase but still an
incredibly high number and the UK is on
that upward curve of Kove aid 19 in
terms of the number of people who are
dying on a daily basis and once the
government is trying to flatten that
curve with the number of measures
they've introduced those numbers are
still continuing to arise so just a
clarification on that for you Kimberley
1228 people have died according to the
latest government figures a bit about
the testing as well the testing
yesterday at this time was a hundred and
twenty thousand seven hundred and
seventy-six that's gone up by just shy
of seven thousand earlier today Michael
Gove telling Sophie Ridge that testing
will be around ten thousand so maybe in
tomorrow's figures we will see that
slight increase of the number of people
that have been tested so far there is an
increase of seven thousand we saw seven
thousand
people being tested from yesterday's
figures as well a further 10 people have
died in Wales after testing positive for
coronavirus now that brings their total
deaths to 48 that's from public health
Wales totally in the UK we're seeing
1228 deaths that's an increase of 209
from the previous results and that's up
by about 20 percent over the past three
days four days or so the average
increase of deaths in the UK is being
around 30% this will bring it down
slightly but we are still seeing the
similar trends to that of what Italy and
Spain were within about a weeks or a
couple of weeks time that's what the
chief scientists are suggesting that we
have between one or two weeks behind the
likes of Italy and Spain countries like
that who are seeing really high numbers
of deaths per day now due to co vid 19
so just to confirm those figures again
for you Kimberly in the UK as of 5 p.m.
28th of March of those hospitalised in
the UK sadly 1228 have died a further
7,000 people or so were tested Michael
Gove saying earlier today that there
were 10,000 people being tested today so
that might be reflected in tomorrow's
update and just also to remind you of
the welsh figures as well a further 10
people have died in Wales after testing
positive for coronavirus and that brings
their total deaths to 48 but I'm sure
we'll have a total number of the UK
where we include Scotland and Ireland
Northern Ireland figures as well we'll
have that for you very shortly here on
Sky News